>>> NEW CNN REPORTING
THIS MORNING ON SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM'S PROPOSED BAN ON
ABORTION AFTER 15 WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY.
A NATIONAL BAN.
A SOURCE TELLS CNN THAT THE
PROPOSAL WAS INTENDED TO ARM
REPUBLICANS WITH A POLICY ISSUE
THEY COULD RALLY AROUND AHEAD OF
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
SENATOR GRAHAM'S CURRENT STANCE
IS A REVERSAL FROM HIS PREVIOUS
POSITION.
>> I'VE BEEN CONSISTENT.
I THINK STATES SHOULD DECIDE THE
ISSUE OF MARRIAGE AND STATES
SHOULD DECIDE THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A LAW, AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL, THAT WOULD
SAY, AFTER 15 WEEKS, NO ABORTION
ON DEMAND, EXCEPT IN CASES OF
RAPE, INCEST, TO SAVE THE LIFE
OF ANOTHER.
>> CONSISTENT, NO.
JOINING US NOW IS CNN CAPITOL
HILL REPORTER MELANIE ZANONA AND
ISAAC DOVARE.
WHY DID THE SENATOR DO THIS?
>> I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN SCRATCHING THEIR HEADS OVER
THIS MOVE.
SO I TALKED TO SOME REPUBLICANS
ABOUT WHY IS LINDSEY GRAHAM
DOING THIS?
IT BOILS DOWN TO THIS.
REPUBLICANS PRIVATELY
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR MESSAGING ON
ABORTION HAS NOT WORKED.
THEIR ATTEMPTS TO RUN AWAY FROM
THE ISSUE HAVE NOT WORKED.
SO THERE ARE SOME IN THE PARTY,
INCLUDING LINDSEY GRAHAM, WHO
THINKS IT'S BETTER TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE HEAD ON AND SHOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HOW THEY FEEL
ABOUT ABORTION AND TRY TO GET
THE DEMOCRATS ON DEFENSE.
BUT OF COURSE NOT EVERYONE IN
THE PARTY AGREES THAT THIS IS A
GOOD STRATEGY RIGHT BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
IT'S NOT A POPLULAR POSITION IN
THE KEY BATTLEGROUND DISTRICTS,
HOUSE CONSERVATIVES ARE DIVIDED
OVER THIS.
I REPORTED THAT, THERE WAS A
HEATED MEETING WHERE YOU HAVE
CONSERVATIVES SOME SAYING IT
GOES TOO FAR, SOME NOT FAR
ENOUGH.
THEY'RE RUOLLING OUT NEXT WEEK
LAW THAT JUST SAYS WE'RE GOING
TO PROTECT THE LIVES OF THE
UNBORN CHILD.
>> IT JUST THROWS THE MIDTERMS
INTO QUESTION.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO IMPACT THE
RESULTS THERE.
INDIANA'S PASSED LAW BANNING
ABORTIONS WENT INTO EFFECT
TODAY.
OHIO'S BAN ON ABORTIONS AT SIX
WEEKS.
THE MAP YOU ARE LOOKING AT, SHOW
THE STATE-BY-STATE CHANGES,
SINCE THE JUNE DECISION TO WIPE
ROE V. WADE OFF OF THE BOOKS.
DEMOCRATS SEE THAT ANGER IS
HELPING THEM IN THE MIDTERM
CAMPAIGN.
NOW, THERE'S GRUMBLING THAT ONE
OF THEIR OWN MIGHT BE GIVING THE
DEMOCRATS A GIFT.
LINDSEY GRAHAM JUST INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION OF BANNING ABORTIONS
AT 15 WEEKS.
NOW, MIDTERM FUEL.
>> IF THERE IS ANY DOUBT ABOUT
REPUBLICANS' TRUE INTENTIONS,
ABOUT THE EXTREME ABORTION
PLANS, THERE'S NO QUESTION AFTER
THIS WEEK.
THEIR PLAN IS PLAIN AS DAY.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO BAN ABORTION
IN EVERY SINGLE STATE AND THEY
WANT TO PUNISH DOCTORS.
>> PATTY MURRAY, A DEMOCRAT ON
THE BALLOT, IN A RACE WE'RE
KEEPING AN EYE ON.
>> WE SHOULD APPLAUD POLITICIANS
THAT MAKE THEIR BELIEFS KNOWN.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS FOR
REPUBLICANS IS THEY WANTED TO
RETURN ABORTION RIGHTS TO THE
STATES.
THIS TAKES THAT OFF OF THE
TABLE.
AND REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES HEARD
THAT.
AND NUMBER TWO, THE DAY THIS
HAPPENED WAS NOT A DAY OF GREAT
ECONOMIC NEWS FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
AND IT COMPLETELY WIPED THAT OUT
OF THE NEWS INSTEAD, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LINDSEY GRAHAM.
AND NONE OF THE SENATE
COLLEAGUES WANTED TO DISCUSS IT.
THEY WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY ALL DAY.
AND YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATS
GLEEFULLY SKIPPING AROUND THE
CAPITOL ALL DAY.
THIS WAS A GIFT FOR THEM.
>> THERE'S PLENTY OF EVIDENCE
OUT THERE.
IN A LOT OF PLACES, NOT
EVERYWHERE, BUT IN A LOT OF
PLACES, THIS IS HELPING THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE SUBURB.
WE SAW THE KANSAS REFERENDUM.
DEMOCRATS THINK THIS HELPS WIN
BACK THE MODERATE REPUBLICANS
AND THE INDEPENDENTS WHO MIGHT
BE READY TO VOTE AGAINST
PRESIDENT BIDEN BECAUSE OF
INFLATION, BECAUSE OF CRIME.
YOU MENTIONED THE DEMOCRATIC
GLEE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
THIS IS SEVERAL OF LINDSEY
GRAHAM'S COLLEAGUES RATHER
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT.
ULTIMATELY, THE CAMPAIGN -- THE
ELECTION WILL BE ABOUT THIS
INFLATION.
>> I DON'T THINKS IN ANYTHING AT
THE NATIONAL LEVEL THAT COMES
CLOSE TO GETTING 60 VOTES.
>> I SUPPORT THIS GOING OUT TO
THE STATES AND LETTING PEOPLE
DECIDE.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR HERE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS WOULD SUPPORT --
HAVE SUPPORTED SOME FORM OF
ABORTION.
IT'S NOT THEY DON'T SUPPORT THIS
ON THE SUBSTANCE.
WHAT THEY DON'T WANT TO DO IS
BRING IT UP RIGHT NOW.
THEY KNOW THIS HAS GALVANIZED
MANY VOTERS, INCLUDING
INDEPENDENT VOTERS AND SUBURBAN
VOTERS AND VOTERS THEY NEED IN
NOVEMBER.
TO TALK ABOUT IT NOW, IT DIVIDES
THE PARTY.
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU NEVER WANT
TO DO EIGHT WEEKS FROM AN
ELECTION.
AND THE ELECTION IS A CHOICE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID THIS OUT
LOUD, IF YOU ELECT REPUBLICANS
THIS KIND OF THINGS WILL GET A
VOTE.
AND IF YOU ELECT DEMOCRATS, IT
PROBABLY NEVER WILL.
AND THAT'S A MESSAGE THAT
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT VOTERS TO
THINK ABOUT AS THEY ARE TURNING,
SHOULD I VOTE FOR THE DEMOCRAT
OR THE REPUBLICAN IN MY STATE?
FOR SOME VOTERS, THAT MIGHT
STEER THEM TOWARDS THE
REPUBLICANS.
BUT THEY PREFER THAT NOT BE THE
GROUND THAT PEOPLE DECIDE ON.
>> MITCH McCONNELL SAID, IF HE
WOULD -- THE MAN WHO CONTROLS
THE SCHEDULE AND ASSUMING IF
THEY TAKE THE SENATE, HE WOULD
CONTROL THE SCHEDULE AGAIN.
HE WAS DISMISSIVE OF THAT.
>> WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THE
NEW HAMPSHIRE SENATE RACE.
MAGGIE HASSAN, IT'S A TOUGH
STATE.
SHE THINKS THIS ISSUE HELPS HER
IN THE SUBURB WHERE'S THE VOTES
ARE.
>> THIS IS ABOUT WHETHER YOU
TAKE RIGHTS AWAY FROM HALF OF
THE POPULATION.
AND WHETHER THEY ARE GOING TO BE
IN THE EXAMINING ROOM.
>> THANK YOU, SENATOR GRAHAM.
>> THERE'S A REASON DEMOCRATS
ARE FGLEEFUL ABOUT THIS AND
FORCEFUL.
THEY'VE SEEN IT IN THE NUMBERS
AND IN THE KANSAS VOTE.
UP IN UPSTATE NEW YORK.
O
OTHER ELECTIONS SINCE THE DOBBS
RULING.
THEY FEEL THEY CAN GO TO THE
POLLS WITH THIS.
IT'S CHARGED MODERATE VOTERS AND
SOME REPUBLICAN VOTERS THAT
AREN'T HAPPY ABOUT THAT DECISION
AND AREN'T HAPPY ABOUT
REPUBLICANS.
>> AND THE DATA SAYS IT HELPS
THE DEMOCRATS.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT WILL IN
NOVEMBER.
SOME THINK THAT IT COULD BE SO
OVERWHELMING, IT COULD BE A
SURPRISE.
YOU'RE FROM OHIO, THE DEMOCRATIC
RUNNING FOR THE OHIO RACE IN A
DEMOCRATIC FIRST MIDTERM
ELECTION YEAR.
THINKING MAYBE THIS ISSUE HELPS.
>> WITHOUT ABORTION, THIS BABY
WOULDN'T BE ON THE WAY RIGHT
NOW.
MIKE DeWINE HAS BANNED ABORTION
IN OHIO.
I WOULD HAVE DIED WITHOUT MINE.
>> YOU HAD A HORRIBLE STORY
ABOUT THE YOUNG GIRL WHO HAD TO
GO TO ANOTHER STATE, WHO WAS 10
AND ABUSED, TO GET AN ABORTION
IN OHIO.
THEY HAD SOME EXTREMELY TRAGIC
CASES ALREADY THAT HAVE MADE
HEADLINES.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO
HELP SOMEONE LIKE MAN WHALEY.
YOU HAVE SEEN SOME --
CONGRESSMAN RYAN IS SEVERAL
POLLS, AHEAD OF J.D. VANCE AT
THIS POINT.
YOU'VE SEEN VOTER REGISTRATION,
AMONG WOMEN, GO UP IN OHIO.
AS YOU SAID, WE DON'T KNOW IF
THAT WILL HELP DEMOCRATS.
SOME DEMOCRATS THINK IT WILL.